this news was like today oh really oh
Hot Topic pretty uh yeah I would say
it's HT just because no people are gonna
find out about this next year from us
[Music]
has anybody here ever heard of a
streamer by the name of amaranth yes you
know amaranth right uh hot tub streams
no way and and many things of that
nature it's a male or female a female is
it the redhead girl yes yeah she's a
huge uh streamer on Twitch and just in
general she's uh like really big on
adult content just really really major
Creator she does sexy hot tub stuff yeah
she's got major personality they're like
give me five Subs I'll write your name
on my boob and then it's like 25 bucks
and then like 90 people do it through
her stream and well that's a lot of she
makes millions yeah and she for a long
time there's really been not a whole lot
of information about her like she's not
very public about a ton of a private
life and then recently out of nowhere
she's live streaming and like crying and
on the phone with her uh boyfriend or
husband oh husband
and he's just like yelling at her and it
was on stream yeah through this stream
she reveals that he has been forcing her
to do all this and controls her bank
accounts and allegedly also threatened
to kill her dogs if she didn't stream oh
my God yeah and now it's just like big
things holy [ __ ] yeah it's like taking
over this whole like she's massively
popular so it's like a big big thing
yeah well she has the fan base now she
can [ __ ] dip out dang that's crazy
sometimes if I watch her because I I you
would get recommended stuff on Twitch
and I was like I'm gonna click this hot
tub stream and then I look at it I'm
like she doesn't really seem happy about
it but she's just kind of there and I
was like yeah I'm over it how long does
she stream for usually oh she'll do 24
hours like she'll just in the hot tub so
maybe not always in the hot tub but
she'll do 24 straight hours yeah so the
the context for hot tub stream it was
the workaround for girls to do lewd
content on Twitch without getting banned
because you were only allowed to show
yourself the bikini if you were in the
water so they would get these mini hot
tubs put them in their rooms and sit in
them and that way it's a loophole to
still be able to have lewd constantly
have like little blow up pools and [ __ ]
too but
um dude because I I watch Twitch all the
time because my friends stream and good
streamers always are interactive they're
really like their personality really
shines but for her it's like you just
watch her she's literally just like I'm
in the tub okay hey thanks for the
[ __ ] sub you know and it's it's so
popular I don't know it's not like
interactive well she's been around pre
like twitch days like she was she was
just a content creator like she was on
social she was just like a hot girl that
people kind of found and her phone was
already up and then she started
streaming and then it went crazy and
then she started going on of and it went
crazy and so she's just one of those
people that is kind of like a top
Creator in that world so again like her
saying this and making these allegations
and the crazy thing is I don't know the
legality of it because the Dude on the
phone does not know he's being recorded
recorded and I know that California you
can't be doing that was she like
accidentally unmuted or was did she
stream it oh she meant to do it she was
trying to get him to say things so that
the camera will catch him well is there
a legality issue if she's like
threatened and under duress though you
know what I mean well I think that's
what makes it go into uh into a more
complicated Zone because that's like
when you're being kidnapped and then so
you got your phone in your pocket you
know like so that his voices or whatever
you know what I mean like if she's like
at a point where the guy's like you have
to do this or I'm gonna kill your dog
that is pretty yeah you kind of have to
right but then that's the thing is she
was trying to get him to repeat that
verbatim on the phone and he wouldn't do
it like he was like you think he was
watching you think he was watching the
stream yeah why he could have easily
been watching the stream it doesn't
sound like he was they were he was
really like yelling and uh and yeah and
and the messages
she was like showing some texts and uh
even in the text he was threatening to
to blow 500k of her money by donating it
to a bird sanctuary whatever that means
now it's getting really complicated yeah
now we're like donate the money
the birds need it too
the birds should get some money yeah he
does you don't do the stream the birds
win too like everybody's winning in this
ecosystem if somebody just listening
away from him oh man that must be cool
he made other abusive threats like like
threatening to dump her luggage off the
balcony or he threatened to delete her
social media he had coerced her to
broadcast content telling her to commit
to the Grind because it's a good
Financial opportunity
um but he said commit to the Grind but
I'm threatening you by deleting your
social media accounts and ending the
grind that makes no sense crazy [ __ ]
well yeah he definitely sounds crazy in
in the video he sounds nuts no I mean
like he has the best threats by far the
best the best threats I'm gonna [ __ ]
send your money to the bird sanctuary
I'm gonna throw your clothes off a
balcony okay
you want out of social media final
delete your social media accounts so
yeah
she said that her husband always
insisted that he uh remain a secret so
that she can maximize profits from the
streaming and know what he looks like
and also uh I bet she's Russian and also
she's she's described her life as
because she's insanely rich but she's
described it as living in a fancy prison
oh oh that sucks would you rather live
in a fancy prison
or deadbeat reality that'd be reality
every time baby every time every time
because we men right can
you all right yeah I'm a man dude it
didn't hurt nice yeah so I wonder if
she's gonna continue to stream after all
this like but like yeah on her own she
probably like traumatized like probably
wants nothing to do with it probably
wants to live a private life deadbeat
but real
no I don't know if you remember she was
selling I mean other people have done
this but she was selling
fart jars for a thousand dollars I know
that's that's what I I know who this is
but then she did it too and then she was
telling her she was telling her bath
water so this is why girls were selling
bath water is because they would stream
in these these like workarounds well
they were doing it prior to the
workarounds it would just be a thing to
sell because you just would sing in bath
water well you live in a crazy world
dude dude I'd sell my bath water in a
heartbeat I know but if there was a
market for it I would you know why don't
you just sell your Jujitsu sweat
no thank you man but yeah she's um a
thousand dollars for a fart jar dude
that's crazy and by the way she was
selling out she couldn't fart fast
enough she found no supplies this just
was moving it's like I'm dry
I don't even want to look up let's look
up a network do you think when they open
it up it really does smell like a fart
though probably if they if they
irritated pull your money back for how
long do you think they have the
sensation I don't know like imagine if
it's like a six day shipping here is oh
[ __ ] that's right that [ __ ] probably at
that point I wouldn't even fart anymore
because I can't fart I should probably
just take a dump leave then continue to
collect fumes into like new jars you
know what I mean that's why you're the
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] right supply and demand
yes ma'am right there's so many
different
um net worth estimates for her so I'm
just gonna read the what or some
ballpark figs makes per month and it's
about a million and a half does it say
how many uh subscribers she has on
Twitch yeah
I know twitch just changed it that
twitch is kind of going down the [ __ ]
right now so like the big content
content creators used to get 70 of all
their subs and then 30 and then like
small creators because I used to stream
too right it's 50 50. now everybody's 50
50. so like usually what we used to do
is like just times whatever their number
was by five because that's like the
minimum you can sub it was like like
Nick Merck steffel makes you know
freaking like maybe like 400 500 000 a
month she has
um 13 528
active subscribers so yeah then you just
times that by five so he's number 57 in
the ranking times them by five and
divided by half yeah and that's like how
much money but that doesn't even because
sometimes people do like tier three Subs
which are like 25 bucks a month yeah and
stuff so if you just do the bare minimum
five bucks and her of in terms of that
is probably killing twitch a million and
a half a month that's crazy that's
that's just of like her whole thing so
this is her if you've never seen her
that's what she looks like just for
context hot tub stream yeah and that's
what a hot tub stream essentially pretty
much looks like yeah I thought you were
going to bring up that other porn star
Adrian cheshnick or whatever that went
to Twitch twitchcon in San Diego this
past weekend or last week jumps into the
[ __ ] foam pit doing the toe touch and
then breaks two of her vertebrae yeah a
lot of people what was in the foam pit
though nothing it was just it wasn't
deep enough yeah that's what they were
saying it was just the ground it wasn't
deep enough it was like enough pieces of
foam to Maybe cover the ground but it
wasn't really covering the ground
another like streamer dislocated her
knee and [ __ ] that's probably gonna be
on Lenovo huh or on Twitch do you think
whoever [ __ ] said that stupid ass the
booth is Lenovo isn't it I don't know I
don't know make it deeper no Lenovo used
to be IBM that makes sense but then
Lenovo bottom out I know it's because I
sold the computers for a little bit cool
any other computer fun facts
tell us something about computers
Dell was affordable back then though you
know did you know
that's a good moment yeah so uh this
kind of brings to light a lot of
situations that might be happening
within the world of streaming because it
kind of works like [ __ ] pimps you
know what I mean like uh I know that of
I've met some guys that uh that manage
accounts for women they'll have like 10
women under them and they'll just
constantly shoot content for them and
they'll be like wear this this week and
then we'll do that and all they do is
show up to get the pictures taken he
takes a cut of everything their of makes
and there's a ton of these everywhere so
maybe they'll get into situations where
they're gonna have to kind of
investigate these a little harder to
make sure before you start that this is
something that you really are doing on
your own independent decision no guy in
the back pulling strings or nothing man
that's really hard that's scary dude it
makes twitch seem like such a dark place
because it's supposed to be like for
like a positive Gaming Community
everyone's here to hang out but then
it's so much like our stuff behind it
well how long have a lot of uh Gamers
been trying to Lobby against like girls
selling themselves on Twitch because it
ruined the platform for them you know
yeah I remember too when they made the
whole hot tub streamer thing this it was
recent like within the past couple years
do you feel like that's running twitch I
mean not really just don't click on that
section right right I think this would
be ruining yeah a lot of things bigger
than rooning twitch because if if twitch
is giving the platform where people you
know are going to make this much money
to the point of a desperate dude pushing
his girl to do it exactly there needs to
be something in place that can prove it
that's not happening yeah that's really
complex so it's like not really on the
platform too much right like that's like
um Facebook getting in trouble for
certain things but like that that's such
a slippery slope of a conversation both
from a legal standpoint to a free speech
place you know what I mean to
you know the twitch is just the platform
right they're not the ones quote unquote
like forcing anybody to like sign up for
this stuff or whatever so it's kind of
sketch hope she gets out of that
situation the thing that I I feel like
makes a difference is that in of
whatever that's the wild west do
whatever you want to do twitch has a lot
of [ __ ] kids yeah 100 that's the
difference kids go there so like try a
little harder maybe like do a wellness
check no that's true all it takes is one
person to give you a call and go hey
this is you doing this right dude that's
true because there's that loophole it's
like these kids are watching hot tub
streams like that makes no sense here of
course they're gonna watch hot dogs I
mean kids the kids are going to do what
kids do but like they didn't say
anything like what anything that's
happened after or no development so far
so by the time this is out is she still
streaming right now or she have has she
been like unfortunately she wants her
dog to stay alive man this news was like
today oh really oh Hot Topic pretty uh
yeah I would say it's HT just because no
people are gonna find out about this
next next year from us because if
something really bad happens then yeah
well this we can't even use this video
yeah but yeah hoping the best for a
great Creator that's a sucky thing for
that to buy more home for the bird
sanctuary right here dude
[Music]
[Music]